hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
advanced phenotyping of the tumor immune
micro
environment i am jennifer woods of
labyrinth
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
altiview to learn more visit ultavu.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or
hearing the presentation i'd like to now
welcome our speakers
dr angela sasaturo associate director
biomarker strategy and applications and
dr fabian fabian schneider r
d and product management at vizio farm
doctor vasaturo you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the kind introduction and
good afternoon everyone
today i'd like to start with a quick
introduction on the
tumor immune microenvironment
as you can see in this very elegant
representation the tumor
microenvironment is extremely complex
it not only consists of tumor cells but
also many other different cell
populations
including uh cells of the innate and
adaptive immunity
that play an important role in
especially response to therapy
and it's actually this complexity that
drives the need
of using multiplex immunistic chemistry
that allows
the analysis of multiple immune cell
phenotypes
and their spatial distribution and
interactions
multiplex ihc becomes also critical when
working with the very precious clinical
samples
trying to provide data to make a
decision on whether or not
to move a drug forward so in this
context the selection of the appropriate
tissue biomarker
coupled with the spatial analysis
becomes really key for generating
as compelling as possible data for from
the
very few samples that are available at
this initial
stage of clinical trials and this is not
always the case so
data are sometimes inconclusive
or the biomarkers that have been
selected
are not predictive or simply the assay
shows not to be reproducible or
it's too complex to to move in the in
the path
or towards clinical development
so when working with patient material
you want to make most of the tissue you
have
therefore you want to have the full
slide analyzed
you want to be able to look at the
spatial relationships in the tumor micro
environment
you want to generate highly consistent
data and ideally you want to combine
your biomarkers of choice with hne on
the same slide
and hne on the same slide is extremely
powerful
when trying to scale to
larger studies but also when you want to
simplify the assay based on
promising indications that the drug
works so when you
when you want to work with the training
clinical trials and you want to optimize
the the chances of
being successful you need to start from
the selection of the
uh of the most powerful biomarkers by
testing um
multiple competing hypotheses at the
same time this is why
um we like to have
um up to eight biomarkers on the same
slide
plus an h and e on the same exact slides
uh to be able to generate consistent
data that that are also critical
for algorithm training
multiplex ihc is often still perceived
as a very complex technology
and although the tme is complex your
assay shouldn't be
and this is actually the aim of the
institute flex technology that altivio
has developed
that made really multiplex simple and
allows
to go from tissue to data in a one-day
workflow
so the staining is pretty simple
and takes very short time and
allows for whole slide imaging and the
very
deep phenotyping and spatial mapping
that you will hear about
in the next presentation
here a very quick overview of the inc
duplex technology that
really follows just a few steps the
first one is an antigen retrieval
only one that allows the preservation of
the tissue integrity and the h e on the
same exact slide
where we perform fluorescent multiplex
ihc
then a staining step where we incubate
the sample with a
mixture of dna barcoded antibodies
followed by an amplification step where
the dna barcode is
elongated to allow more complementary
fluorescent dna
probes to bind in the last step which is
a detection
step and at this point your samples are
ready to be imaged
so with this simple technology there is
a complete retention of sample
antigenicity
and the morphology of the tissue and the
architecture of the tissue is well
preserved
that allows hne on the same slide and
therefore it's fully compatible with the
conventional pathology
it is also a very high throughput
technology that can be applied across
multiple tumor indications without the
need
of re-optimization and it can be also
easily
transferred to cro outsourcing partners
for uh clinical research implementation
so this slide summarizes the initial of
tv offering of the inc dublex technology
here you see a different uh ultima upper
kits
that are all four plex kits that include
a different combination of markers that
allow to explore complex phenotypes
and allow to answer specific biological
questions on the
tumor microenvironment for example
there's a kit that
looks around antigen presenting cells uh
or myeloid there are suppressor cells or
also
um activated t cells regulatory t cells
but also
uh phenotypes along the pd-1 and pl1
axis
more recently this standard offering
with the off-the-shelf kits has been
extended to an additional kit which is
now
an eight plex panel that we call ultima
per immuno8
that i will focus on in the in the next
couple of slides
but uh the ltb offering is also extended
now
um to a custom assay development so we
have a dedicated
asset development team that can
build your custom panel up to an eight
plex
uh in eight to thirteen weeks in total
this is an overview of the immuno 8
panel that we have recently developed
that includes the main
phenotypic and functional markers for
the key immune phenotypes that
are critical in the tumor
microenvironment
what i would like to highlight here is
that
as for all the other kits and also for
the custom kits
the um the panels that we develop
can be applied to multiple indications
without
need of re-optimizing any conditions and
here you see an example of the immunoadd
panel
run on multiple tissue types
including non-small cell and cancer
colorectal cancer and
breast cancer and in the next couple of
slides i will focus on the application
of the
immunoload panel on the colorectal
cancer tissue
so on this slide you can see on the left
side an overview of
a colorectal cancer tissue stained with
the
immunoadd panel and um a zoom on
one liter area where you can see uh some
tumor-ness and but also a lot of
infiltrating cells immune infiltrating
cells and now the
immunoadd panel includes uh markers
that allow the uh to identify uh the key
t cell phenotypes um including
regulatory t
cells exhausted t cells cytotoxic t
cells but also
immunivating tumor cells or immune
suppressive macrophages so it really
gives
a lot of information on the dynamic
nature of the tumor microenvironment
and again based on the combination of
different markers including
cd3 cd8 cd4 fox p3
pdl1 pd1 cd68
and cytokeratine you can test
multiple hypotheses at the same time and
identify
really the meaningful phenotypes the
meaningful biomarkers
that give clinical utility
and here i just wanted to show you a
couple of examples of the
quality of the staining but also the
different phenotypes that you can
identify
like in this image in this slide you
have a cd3 in green
and then you have cd4 in red so the
combination of cd3 and cd4
allow you to identify t helper cells and
then if you add
fox p3 in white in the nucleus
uh then you will be able to look at the
t-rex
and in the in the right panel here
bottom right panel um i have added
just the cytokeratin in cyan to be able
to
uh show where those different cells are
located
as you can see there are some that are
really intra-epithelial so intra-tumor
and some others that are really between
the different tumor nests
next um in in this specific case for
example i have highlighted the
cytotoxic t cells t-cells identified by
the combination of cd3 in green and cd8
in red but i have also added on top of
it the pd1 in yellow that
allows the identification of exhausted
t-cells
and in this case you can see that most
of them are uh
cd8 pd1 expressing cells
again the cytokine in addition to be
able to
look at the localization of the
different phenotypes and as you can see
there are
multiple pd1 positive cells that are
located
within the tumor nests
last you see in pink here pdl1 staining
and its combination with either cd68 in
white
or uh pan cytokeratine in cyan and this
allows you to identify release cells
that express pdl1
which are not necessary only tumor cells
but also
uh can be macrophages and in this
specific tumor you
you might be able to see in the lower
left panel that most of the pdl-1
is expressed on macrophages rather than
on
tumor cells and in the in the bottom
right panel i have
um added pd1 so that
we can look at the um interaction
between pd1 and pdl1 expressing cells
and again i have kept the cytokeratine
staining to be able to
look at the the specific
localization of those positive cells
with respect to tumor
and with these slides i i really want to
summarize and reiterate the concept of
the power of using an eight plex assay
to test
multiple hypothesis at the same time on
the same exact tissue section and then
select
the most promising biomarker subset that
are the ones that
would give the clinical utility so
eventually what you would do is
testing the multiple hypothesis by using
up to eight biomarkers but
go down in the number of plagues in the
number of biomarkers that are really
meaningful to your trial
and eventually transfer this to your cro
choice and
for clinical deployment on a larger
court
so although we of course highlight the
power of multiplex we still believe that
ideally you want to get to the least
number of plex
and the least number of phenotypes that
are really able to give you the clinical
utility that you look for
and that can be easily deployed in
in a larger study at the cro
and last but not least i have mentioned
previously in the during the
presentation that we can perform hne on
the same slide where we perform
multiplex if and again this is extremely
powerful and we can do that because of
the
type of acid we are using that preserves
the tissue architecture and the cellular
morphology
and this is really not adding a lot of
time to your
staining procedure and it follows the
exact same protocol that is
used in in pathology labs but it is
something extremely powerful
especially from the fact that
it adds uh the uh uh phenotyping of
functional
uh information to an image that
is what pathologists look at and gives
them
the morphological features that are
eventually driving diagnosis for example
so if you look at this image a
pathologist would be
really comfortable in saying what is
tumor and uh
what is stroma but also it will be easy
for a pathologist to
to say as well that there are a lot of
um infiltrating cells what becomes
complicated it's seeing
what is the function of the cells and if
those are exhaustive t cells or
if they are cytotoxic t cells so and
this is where the
additional uh if um data
and information come in and the
combination of the two is really
uh what gives uh most what takes most
out of a simple tissue that can be
extremely precious and uh with this um
i like i'd like to thank you all for
your attention
thank you very much angela for the great
introduction to the io8 plex and your
technique
my name is fabian schneider and i will
show you
how the visual farm platform can be
utilized
to decipher all the phenotypes that
an io 8 like so an 8 marker multiplex sa
delivers so in the background you
already see
the crc case on which we will demo
our capabilities of our platform
and you already see quite an overlay of
markers
and where the cell types are um
touching each other
in immuno ecology the cellular
phenotypes of the immune system
and markers on the tumor are of utmost
importance
to understand mechanism of actions of
new drugs
and for this we need to understand where
are the cell types and their
interactions
what are the distributions of these
phenotypes that are resulting from the
markers
where is the receptor and ligands in the
immune cancer signups and are they
correlating
i would like to introduce you to the
visiopharm software
which is a toolbox for image analysis
scientists
in which you can combine the rule-based
machine learning with artificial
intelligence deep learning classifiers
all your outputs that you would like to
generate are fully customizable
and no coding is required from the user
and we have a lot of modules with which
you can extend
the functionalities of your platform for
example
tissue array in which you can use your
tissue microarrays in brightfield and
fluorescence you can deray the cores
and for an individual analysis of each
we have the multiplex phenotyping
module which gives you an automated
unbiased clustering tool
for the analysis of hyplex data
we have a tissue align module with which
you can core register seriously sections
and stained images across modalities
like ihc and agent e ihc
agent e and multiplex if
we also have one uh product that is
called the brain mapper
for the mouse brain on which we have a
pre-built atlas
with deep learning classifiers to
identify
mouse brain regions horizontal and
sagittal sections and you can
identify the new biomarkers and quantify
them within the different regions
today's problem is the immunoaplex
and the phenotype analysis
so the first thing that you need to do
is you need to segment the tissue
into the blue here the cancer versus the
stromal regions
then what you would do is you do a
second app
is a cell detection so you need to
identify all the nuclei
and then you can expand the nuclei into
a cell segmentation
and then you can phenotype with the
underlying
presence of the of the biomarkers
which will then result into many
different classes of
positivity for these biomarkers
and we offer this based on machine
learning
classifiers or and we can combine this
with ai deep learning capabilities
and then once you have your cell
segmentation you can run an automated
phenotyping
with the phenotyping module
what we have used for the tissue
segmentation as well as
for the cell segmentation we have used
the
ai deep learning classifier what you
will get out is
simple results like um box and bar
graphs
that you can report the positivity of
cells or percentages or densities
you can show the results also as heat
map overlays on the tissue directly
to display the distribution of your
phenotypes across the tissue
another thing is that you can calculate
all the distances between classes
so phenotypes or regions and can export
this into
into your output files and then generate
distance measurements and further on you
can also display
all your phenotypes in phenographs so
this is a
dimensionality reduction where you can
look at the
display and the clustering and you can
look at the fingerprint
of your tissue samples and compare them
to each other to see differences
in the combination of the phenotypes
within
the tissue the first thing you do for
the image analysis is to limit
your analysis to a region of interest
in green we have detected automatically
the tissue
and have annotated in blue
here on the iaf image the region of
interest for the tumor region
an expert pathologist can also do this
as offered by
altiview directly on the h e stained
tissue image that is available together
with the mif on the same section
after annotating the region of interest
we use the cytokeratin
channel to generate with a deep learning
classifier
a ck segmentation within the region of
interest
to separate the tumor epithelial region
from
the strong
the invasive margin around the tumor
epithelial
segmentation is shown here in with two
margin zones of each 50 micrometer
diameter
one in cyan and one in red which
will later be also used in the data
analysis where you can then show the
distribution
and the densities of the phenotypes
within
these different areas
if we look in more detail at the
tissue segmentation and the invasive
margins you see in blue the ck
segmentation
and also within these margins that are
far from the tumor mass you see
some single cells that are ck expressing
this could be either invasive cancer
cells or
this could be reactive stromal cells but
the more you find of these
and you can quantify this then with our
software
the more you can look into the
invasiveness
of such a cancer case and give a
predictive
and this has a predictive value for the
survival of the patients
the immuno 8 plex as already shown by
my ltb colleague is super high plex and
very information dense so if you look at
all 8 markers at once
we are not cognitive uh capable to
try to sub identify and deceive this
image so when you look at this region
and we only look at the lineage markers
then we already see that
a lot of these cd4 expressing cells
and are surrounding together with the
macrophages
the the tumor islands here
so they are like delineating it
and you see within the tumor epithelium
you see
cd8 positive cells
and what i want to focus today is the
cytotoxic t
cells and when they are becoming either
exhausted or primed with the expression
of pd1
which is available in this kit and
macrophages and tumor cells that are
expressing pdl1
so the first thing we are doing when
uh when we want to do the phenotyping a
set is that we have to segment the cells
here you see the result and the layer
mask of the cell segmentation
for the whole slide and for this region
then we do the phenotyping on top of
that and here i'm
only showing you some lineage markers so
you see
here are our macrophages
here are the tumor cells in purple we
have the
cd8s in green and we have
cd3 in cyan and cd4s in
pink
and we can already see that macrophages
seem to shield
the tumor from the invading
t-cell compartment if we add on top
our functional markers to the lineage
markers
we see that the fox p3 positive cells
are intermingled with
the macrophages
and the pdl1 positivity is
mainly on the macrophage population in
this case
really shielding and delineating
exactly at the line of the tumor
epithelium
the tumor from the um from the t cells
and pd1 expressing cells
are either in contact in in the invasive
margin with these pdi1
expressing macrophages as you see or
are on the tumor
we can also visualize this a bit um
more easy by only showing with our
software
dots on top of these cells that you can
then
give specific colors to see the grouping
of your of your cells
here as that i would like to focus on
the capabilities for
distribution of these biomarkers so you
see
the heat map for cytokeratin on the left
in the middle you see the heat map for
[Music]
cd68 for macrophages and
cds3 cda double positive cells
the heat maps are all normalized so that
the yellow color is around 300
cells per square millimeter density
if we then add the functional marker
pdo1 and pd1 on top then you see that
ck positive pedia1x double
expressing cells are mainly in the
region down here
and some scattered cells in the tumor
while cd68pl1 double positives have a
hotspot
also correlating with the
ck expression and are
around the tumor islands that are
towards the larger stromal areas
and the cd3 cd8 pd1 triple positive
cells
these are mainly around the whole tumor
tissue
and are also on the tumor epithelium
we can also combine the two heat maps
for visualization
and by multiplying pdl1 here with a cd8
pd1 double positives and this leads to
this phenotype
clustering where you see that the um the
spatial correlation
is the has the highest
possibility around this area
and around these two areas where you
have the ck
and pdf1 expression and the pdl1
high macrophage regions
when we are exploring the tumor
epithelium versus the storm densities of
our phenotypes
we can clearly see that in the stroma we
have
higher expressions of the t cells
compared
to the tumor epithelial area and we also
have
more macrophages
macrophages in both populations cg68
only or double positives with pdl1 so
the more m2
like phenotypes in the stroma
for the cd8s this is
the opposite so we have more cd3 cd8s
that are unprimed
within the stroma and on the tumor
epithelium
most of the cd8s become
positive we can also look at
more rare phenotypes that are identified
for example
cd8 cells that express fox p3 and
cd8 fox p3s that are also pd1 positive
or cd4s and cda double positive cells
and cd4 ct8 fox p3
triple positive cells etc
but if you think back into the
[Music]
marginal zone segmentation we did we can
also investigate
where are these cells at the highest
density or this
is this on the tumor as for cd8 with pd1
expression
and there we see that we have a clear
draw between the inners inner
in invasive margin and
the and the tumor epithelium
while the cd3 cd8 are
also more distributed across
these three areas
this is also similar for the cd68s that
are pda1 positive
so they are similar in density
between the two margins
for cd8 and pdl1
a direct interaction is important
therefore we can also do special
analysis of
our phenotypes by looking at the cell
cell contact
for this we use our cell segmentation
mask and then bring out the phenotypes
so only the cd8 expressing cells
and then we look at all cells that are
in direct contact
with these cd8s
and then we can take these as another
class
out and sub phenotype these then further
um and look which are the cells that
have the highest frequency in contact
with our cd8
and this we can do for all phenotypes
and we can
do this experiment over and over for all
of the resulting phenotypes and then
compare across cases
visualfarm's platform offers multiple
possibilities to explore the represented
classes
in the whole slide tissue or your
biopsies or tissue microarrays
so you can look at phenotype profiles
where you see the percent of
positivity and that is identified of
these
different phenotypes as a bird's eye
view bar graph
heat map for example we have the
possibility to also use disney
dimensionality reduction
to to investigate the clustering of
different phenotypes
and also to look at the fingerprints of
your samples
you can then also look at the phenotype
matrixes
which phenotypes are expressed
within your cases and you can also
look at the neighborhood plot that is
available within our software
to understand if your cytotoxic t cells
are clustering for example with
proliferating cells in general
with this i hope i could show you that
the visual form multiplexing analysis
capabilities are powerful
and that with the io8 plex by altiview
we can explore a lot of phenotypes and
also identify them
and look at the interactions of all of
these cells so
i only showed you one aspect of looking
at p1 pdl1 axis
on cytotoxic t cells and
macrophages and tumor cells but you
the you can look at all different
combinations like
fox ps3 cd4 distances to cd8 or
the clustering of pdl1 cd4 double
positive
regulatory cells or t helper cells 2
cd8 pd1 expressing cells
and what is this relation to the general
pdl1
expression you can look at all different
distances
in which you are interested in and
get them as an output and you can
compare
all of this to other cases so you can
apply the same algorithms to the same
uh essays on on the same indication
or tweak for the next indication and
move your analysis forward so visu farm
offers this flexible toolbox
to build your own apps so algorithms
and workflow to answer your specific
scientific questions
you can use deep learning classifiers
and train them by example
by defining regions for the analysis or
measurements
all the app workflows are fully
customizable and
all outputs are accessible and you get
the numbers you need
or export the entire data set so you are
not limited to that
and our platform is fully integrated
with the multiplex phenotyping workflow
for
automated phenotyping
with this i would like to thank you for
your attention
and thank all of you for giving us the
opportunity to
present our phenotyping capabilities
for high plaques in fluorescence essays
i would like to thank our product team
for the phenotyping in computer vision
and ai at the visual farm
and david mason for pre for providing me
the skeleton for this slide deck
looking forward to the q a session
together with angela
and looking forward to your questions
thank you
thank you dr vasaturo and dr schneider
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started okay our first
question
is
have you tried also other stains besides
h and e after the altiview procedure
such as the good quality pcr
i guess this for me yes arm sorry
yes so um we haven't tried it
but i don't think there would be any
issue because basically we have used hne
uh since it is the most commonly used
um staining in routine pathology
um and basically proves the fact that we
are not affecting the the tissue in any
ways in terms of uh
um architecture and cellular morphology
so
i guess whatever other staining like the
one
that was mentioned here uh i guess is
the
bigger serious thread for collagen
fibers should be uh something applicable
but we haven't tried it
thank you dr vasaturo the next question
is
um how does the antigen retrieval work
um one more question for me so um it's
basically the classical antigen
retrieval that you would perform
also for um chromogenic ifc like dab
staining uh so the protocol that we use
is um
fully optimized to run on the bond
directs so usually this is
here two which means uh ph nine
but the three if you would do it
manually would any
of the classical integer retrieval book
can be used
okay thanks again dr vasuduro let's see
um let's i think that dr schneider is
still
trying to get his audio connected for
the q a so
let's see if i ask a question that's for
him we'll just let me know
and we can postpone that until he's
connected
so our next question is would this
system be cost effective for large
sample sets
ie 70 samples or better suited for
smaller amounts of slides
i'm not sure if this is a question
related to the staining portion
or the uh um analysis portion
uh and i think it's a question that
might
be if it's a staining related it might
be a better question to be addressed
afterwards with the with the sales team
i can't really comment on on some on
costs okay thank you we really
appreciate that
and the next question is is it the
phenographs
module on market can you explain a bit
more what it is
i was just wondering if this is the
clustering algorithm or something else
yes so now i'm back so um
my internet connectivity here in my
holidays site is very bad
i'm sorry for that yes the phenograph
model is
uh on market and this is
an automated clustering with using a
gaussian mix model
and we are currently working on updating
that
in the future
oh great we're glad you're back thank
you dr schneider our
our next question is is it possible to
visualize and
analyze and analyze of any particular
biomarker combination
on aggregate data from different groups
of tissues
eg tumors from treated and untreated
tumors
yes if the essay is the same and the
indication is the same
it is absolutely no problem to analyze
this
from different cases so the you can
train the model on several images
from from the same essay and then
transfer it on
further samples and see how well it um
behaves on these samples
all right thank you dr schneider and we
have another question for you
just wondering about the overlay of ihc
and
um if it's sorry my we have so many
questions coming in my my screen is
skipping okay
um is that mean we can overlay
then make an app to analyze further
yes so i think that you are referring to
transfer learning with this
question and yes you can do this so you
can
um if this is stained on the same tissue
section like with the altiview
um or if you have a serial true
serial cut sections then you can
co-register these and transfer the
information from one slide to the next
and our core registration is very
powerful and can
do this in most of the cases and then
you can
[Music]
learn one thing for example with if to
the agent e
and transfer this and create your new
algorithms to directly
identify cells in agente for example
all right thanks again dr schneider and
there's another question
actually two questions for you two
questions and one
is this um voice i'm sorry is the deep
learning process
algorithm explainable from the
regulatory point of view
and any hope timeline for fda or ce
certification of the software
as a medical device for clinical
diagnostics
okay so i don't think that any of the
deep learning process algorithm
are yet explainable for regulatory point
of view
we would have to to look into this
question and get back to you but if you
shoot me an email i can
definitely bring this to our regulatory
um
chief of our regulatory department and
discuss this with istanbul
and for the fda or ce certification
we have um ivd e marked
apps for ihc markers like kr67
her2 erp are tumor
nest detection in agent e and lymph
nodes from breast cancer patients
so yes that is possible but you need a
lot of training material and a lot of
sites and need to coordinate
to get this approved
all right thanks again dr schneider and
you'll have an opportunity to
you know connect after this we really
appreciate you
doing that okay our next question is
how does the cell segmentation work
based on nuclear
nuclei expansion or also by other labels
yes so the current cell segmentation
works on the expansion of
the nuclei so this is the first thing
what we do
we can also um incorporate
training that you learn from the lineage
markers
and the but this is something what you
would have to do on your own currently
so the
the algorithm doesn't know this yet
all right thanks again dr snyder let's
have another question
can you comment on antibody stripping
and reprobing and what makes ulta view
so different
yes so um antibody stripping is
something that we don't do
at all uh so basically we perform one
single
um incubation of primary antibodies so
everything happens simultaneously we do
not need to do
sequential staying and therefore we do
not need the antibody stripping
and this is something that can really
affect the antigenicity of your tissue
as well as the tissue morphology uh
which we
try to avoid completely so what this uh
what makes all tv so different is really
uh the fact that we do uh one single
step for each of the um um
step requires for the staining so
retrieval is only one um
antibody primary antibody incubation is
only one and then we also add on top of
that
uh an amplification step which is um
increasing the the signal to noise and
then allows a better
more consistent data and the better
algorithm development
thank you dr pataturo we have another
question coming
in let's see what are the specific
tissue requirements
is the technology amenable to needle
biopsy or even small metastatic tumor
samples
well i think this question goes very
much with the previous one in the sense
that
you know when you are performing
sequential staining and you need to
repeat
a kind of retrieval or use a stripping
step
and you are working with very small
samples or like needle biopsies then you
are afraid that your basically your
tissue can fall off the slide but in
in this specific case with the optical
technology we do not have this
risk so there is no special requirement
other than the classical ones that you
would have also for
any other ihc thing so
you want to have uh slides that have
been cut
recently you don't want to um have
epidural degradation before you perform
the staining so you need to
pay attention uh to your slides but also
you know most of it is done at the very
initial phases when you collect the
samples and the way you embed them the
way you preserve them
which is something typically done uh
and taken care of for any type of
staining so
the short answer is that no specific
requirements are there and
we can work with very small tissues as
well
thank you dr vasaturo our next question
is
cells in solid tissue are usually close
together or close to each other
forming clumps and or overlapping with
each other
how does the vizio farm software deal
with that
yeah that's a great question so that's
something that um
the user would then need to um train
also the deep learning classifier
and the more uh
the more general you cut your sections
at the same
section thickness the better your um
your model will behave on your um on
your samples
but we we cannot guarantee that all the
cells that are overlapping with each
other
are um are identified correctly
and for this even if especially when
they have the same lineage markers then
it's becoming tricky for the algorithm
but for this we would like to to
introduce also
in the future that you that the users
can
can correct for these mistakes
thanks thank you dr schneider
our next question is what qualifies an
ultraview technology antibody versus a
standard
ihc antibody great question
so the antibodies that we use are
usually the clinical relevant clones
when they are available so basically
there is no difference between an
antibody that you would use for the
classical ifc dab staining or an
antibody that you want to use in the
with the isp technology so uh and
the the proof for that is also that um
uh
dab staining is still our gold standard
so whenever we work with an antibody
that is developed to work on paraffin
embedded samples then this can be used
can be developed for isp and we will
always start from dab
testing the sensitivity and specificity
of the antibody and then we will
conjugate it with our dna barcoding
repeat the staining in dab to make sure
that this has not affected the
performance of the antibody
and then eventually move it into
fluorescence so
we can work with any antibody that has
been
developed for um paraffin samples
thank you dr vazaturo and another
question
let's see what other software can you
use
for image analysis of the mis
question yeah i think i would take this
question because
well visio farm of course and that we
have seen it in action but um
in principle we are not limited to any
specific
uh software um so we work also with
other
partners for image analysis and uh
the choice really depends on the depth
of the phenotyping you want to do when
the complexity of the analysis you want
to perform
um so you might even think if you just
want to look at the
density of a single lineage marker
you can even use the the freely
downloadable software that are online
but of course if you
um if you want to do a much uh deeper
analysis and you want to understand more
and you want to go into
a spatial distribution proximity
analysis et cetera then you need to use
um a software like the busy form
thank you dr uh i'm sorry i'm trying to
read questions and talk at the same time
so the next question is um do you have
any recommendations
regarding section thickness to get gold
good multiplex staining
as well as cell detection
well i can talk through the um thickness
for staining we usually work with
the classical three to five microns
slide um
it really depends a little bit also on
the customer request
so in-house i think usually we use four
micron slides
thickness but there are some customers
that also request three and some others
that request
five i don't think it changes a lot in
terms of the cell detection because you
are still uh
below uh the um um
size of of the cell so you know that
basically if you look at cedar sections
if you have four or five margarines you
are not looking at the exact same cells
so maybe fabian if you want to comment
further on the thickness and the
how this would impact the analysis yeah
thanks so we have we have tested that
and also in my previous
um jobs we have tested the the section
thickness and we found that
the best consistency we found was three
or four micron
so that was really the best where you
don't have too many cells that are
overlapping
or um or i'm hiding each other
or on top of each other and the more you
will turn into five and six micron
the more you also have section sickness
artifacts
because you can't guarantee always that
you cut at the same
size due to temperature changes etc
all right thank you both and let's see
we've got another question
typically many image analysis tools are
greatly influenced by
inconsistent staining results how does
vizio farm software account for inter
and intra run variability and staining
quality
yeah this is a great question and we get
this asked a lot so
i think our software cannot do anything
about
intel intro run variability if the
variance is
really high so we
um in image analysis you rely
on the input data that you get and if
these are inconsistent then even the
best models cannot
take this into account so
you have some tools at hand that you can
use so for example you can use
one of our normalization tools that we
um recently deployed
where you can also do the normalization
across
images in your batch and we are still
working on how to do the a good
image normalization thresholding
and have this adaptively transferred
onto other images
it looks like thank you so much it looks
like that's all we have time for
for today do either of you have
any final comments for our audience
well i think we have been able to um
convey the message that it's really
important to um
define up from the best biomarkers to
combine and not just think about the
number of markers you can have on the
same slide but really think through the
hypothesis that you want to validate
and then have a very robust reproducible
assay that eventually allows you also to
have a
very robust uh very robust data on the
image analysis side and facilitates also
the
the task of building an algorithm that
can be applied across multiple
indications and
across multiple trials
yes i can just echo that and with one of
the things that one of my former boss
at astrazeneca called barrett was always
saying first think about your hypothesis
before you put the panels together
and i think this is a very wise one and
first we need to all think about what
is the mechanism of action or the proof
of mechanism that you would like to see
because most of the phenotypes that you
are are hunting are already known
and if you would like to combine an
image analysis with your
rna sequencing data from single cells
then you have already maybe new targets
that you would like then alter you to
test
new antibodies on or to develop new
panels and then
you can either have custom made
algorithms from digifarm as a service
or you can develop with our modules your
algorithms on your own and then use them
for
further validating your your new
hypothesis
and your mechanisms of action and maybe
just to really close up on this
um uh i think after you has a quite
strong scientific team that can
help you discussing uh the ideal
combination of markers and
uh consult on on your specific needs
and really help getting the data that
eventually gives you the utility you
need
well thank you again dr vasaturo and dr
schneider for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank labruz and our
sponsor ultavu for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye